Jeff Karl let me tell you something I'm  gonna be honest with you you know your  reputation Carly Simon's a legendary  artist the idea that she's gonna sing  with you and treat it in a serious  manner it's great and what an honor this  yeah everyone she's nervous around you  and understandably yeah but I understand  understandably believe everybody's  giving me the roles so the Royal  shoulder chicken deal dude  now that anger aside I'm gonna let you  sing start the music and let him sing  with you please I'm begging you go ahead  but do a little piano there  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  understand if they're - we don't shine  the ball and that's why yes indeed oh  yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah  Wow what fantastic you know what was  interesting to me you even gave each  other the glance we did all but the  dance I remember when you did that with  James Taylor I thing at him with love  but yet you gave the same look to Jeff